need motivation watch a top-10 belief
nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you as
well you've got Michael Jordan level
talent add something so get ready for
some leadership building ideas from Jeff
Bezos in my take on his top 10 rules a
success vol 5 to give you the belief
that you need
ok let's kick it off with rule number
one act on your ideas I came across the
fact so this is 1994 nobody has heard of
the internet very very few people and I
came across the fact that the web world
wide web was growing at something like
twenty-three hundred percent a year this
is a 1984 and anything growing that fast
is even if it's baseline usage today is
tiny it's growing so fast it's gonna be
big and so I looked at that and I was
like there's got to be I should come up
with a business idea then they get you
know on the internet and then let the
internet go around this and we can keep
working on it and so I made a list of
products that I might saw online I
started forced ranking them and I picked
books because books is super unusual in
one respect which is that there are more
book items in the book category than
there are items in the other cat or the
3 million different books active and in
print around the world in a given time
so my my the founding idea of Amazon was
to build Universal selection of books
the biggest bookstores only had 150,000
titles and so that's what I did and I
you know I hired a small team and we
built we built the software I moved to
Seattle and when you told your parents
you're gonna quit de sha where you're
successful making presumably a fair
amount of money yeah and you told your
wife McKenzie that you're gonna move
across the country what did they all say
they were immediately and reflexively
supportive right after they asked the
question what's the internet rule number
two delight the customers we haven't had
any existential crises knock on wood
if I don't want to jinx anything but
we've had a lot of
kind of dramatic events I remember there
early on we only had a hundred and 25
employees when Barnes and Noble who the
big you at united states bookseller
opened their online website to compete
against us Barnes and noble.com we'd had
about a two-year window we opened in 95
they opened in 97 and at that time all
of the headlines and the funniest were
about how we were about to be destroyed
by this much larger company we had 125
employees and 60 million dollars a year
in annual sales 16 million with an M and
that and Barnes and Noble at the time
had 30,000 employees and about three
billion dollars in sales so if they were
giant we were tiny and we had limited
resources and the the headlines were
very negative about Amazon and the one
that's most minimal our memorable was
just Amazon toast and and so I called it
All Hands meeting which was not hard to
do with just 125 people and we got in a
room and because it was so scary for all
of us this idea that now we finally had
a big competitor that literally
everybody's parents were calling and
saying you know are you okay is the it's
usually the mom's calling and asking
their children are you gonna be ok so
and I said look you know it it's okay to
be afraid but don't be afraid of our
competitors because they're never gonna
send us any money be afraid of our
customers and if we just stay focused on
them and instead of obsessing over this
big competitor that we just got that
will be fine
and I really do believe that I think
that if you stay focused then the more
drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is the the what's
your response to it should be to double
down on the customer satisfying them not
just satisfying them delighting them
rule number three follow your calling
you don't choose your passions your
passions choose you and all of us are
gifted with certain passions and the
people who are lucky are the ones who
get to follow those things and the i/os
advise our young employees or meet with
interns this one you can have and my
kids too you can have a job or you can
have a career or you can have a calling
and if you can somehow figure out how to
have a calling you have hit the jackpot
because that's the big deal
rule number four grow your vision what
propel you to sell things more than
books after books we started selling
music and then we started selling videos
and then I got smart and I I emailed a
thousand randomly selected customers and
asked them besides the things we felt
today what would you like to see us sell
and that answer came back incredibly
long-tailed the way they answered the
question was with whatever they were
looking for at that moment so like ever
one of the answers was I wish you've
sold windshield wiper blades
because I really need windshield wiper
blades and I thought to myself we can
sell anything this way and and then so
then we launched electronics and toys
and many other categories over time and
the vision became because you read the
original business plan it's just books
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 254 series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
the stress primarily comes from not
taking action if you absolutely can't
tolerate critics that don't do anything
new or interesting if everything has to
work in two to three years then that
limits what you can do rule number five
have good role models we all get gifts
and we get certain things our life that
our that we're very lucky about and one
of the most powerful one is who your
early role models are you know you could
be was your grandfather it was in a big
sense my mom and dad but my grandfather
too and you know I had my mom had me
when she was 17 years old and she was
still in high school in Albuquerque New
Mexico
and this is a 1964 I can assure you that
being a pregnant teenager in high school
was not cool in Albuquerque New Mexico
at that time and so it's in in so it was
a very it was difficult for her my
grandfather went to bat for her they
tried to kick her out of school and you
know he they're incredible I had so the
gift I had is I had this incredible
family rule number six maintain a day
one culture now that you have about
600,000 employees I calculated you're
adding about 250 people a day you've
mentioned that you're trying to fend off
day - yeah and you said that day two is
stasis followed by irrelevance followed
by excruciating ly painful decline
followed by death yeah that's why it is
always day one yeah yeah how's that work
well so day one and this is a phrase
that we use at Amazon all the time I've
been using it's in my first annual
shareholder letter from 20 years ago and
we stay it's always day one and it needs
to be day one for the reason that you
just mentioned and how do you it so the
real question for me is how do you go
about maintaining a day one culture you
know it's great to have the scale of
Amazon we have financial resources we
have lots of brilliant people we can
accomplish great things we have global
scope we have operations all over the
world but the downside of that is that
you can lose your nimbleness you can
lose your entrepreneurial spirit you can
lose your that kind of heart that that
small companies often have and so if you
could have best of both worlds if you
can have that entrepreneurial spirit and
heart while at the same time having all
the advantages that come with scale and
scope I think think of the things that
you could do and and so how the question
is how do you achieve that the scale is
good because it makes you robust you
know a big box or can take a punch to
the head the question is you also want
to dodge those punches so you'd like to
be nimble it want to be big and nimble
and I find there are a lot of things
that are protective of the day one
mentality I already spent some time on
one of them which is customer obsession
I think that's the most important thing
if you can and it gets harder as you get
bigger when you're a little tiny company
for your 10 persons startup company
every single person the company is
focused on the customer when you get to
be a bigger company you've got all the
middle you've got middle managers and
you've got all these layers and the
those people aren't on the front lines
they're not interacting with customers
every day they're insulated from
customers and they start to manage not
the customer happiness directly but they
start to manage through proxies like
metrics and processes and some of those
things can become bureaucratic so it's
very challenging but one of the things
that happens is the decision-making
velocity slows down and I think the
reason one of the reasons that that
happens is that people also junior
executives inside the big company start
to model all decisions as if they are
heavyweight irreversible highly
consequential decisions and so even
two-way doors you could make you make a
decision it's the wrong decision you can
just back up back through the door and
try again
even those reversible decisions start to
be made with heavyweight processes and
so you can teach people that these
pitfalls and and and traps and then
teach them to avoid those traps and
that's what we're trying to do at Amazon
so that we can maintain our
inventiveness and our hearts and our
kind of small companies spirit even as
we have the scale and scope of a larger
company rule number seven be a good
leader I'm actually a big fan of
anecdotes in business not building a
narrative structure around them
necessarily but I still have an email
address that customers can write to I
see most of those emails and I don't
answer very many of them anymore but but
I see them and I and I forward them some
of them the ones that catch my curiosity
I forward them to
the executives in charges that area but
with a question mark and that question
mark is just a shorthand for can you
look into this why is this happening
what does what's going on and what I
find is strange because we have tons of
metrics we have you know weekly business
reviews with these metric decks and we
look at our we know so many things about
customers and they're there you know
whether we're delivering on time what
you know whether the packages have too
much air in them and you know wasteful
of packaging and so on we have so many
metrics that we monitor and the thing I
have noticed is that when the anecdotes
and the data disagree the anecdotes are
usually right there's something wrong
with the way you're measuring it and
that's why it's so important to to keep
your you need to run it something that
you were you're doing you know shipping
billions of packages a year for sure you
need good data and metrics are you
delivering on time you deliver on time
in every city are you delivering on time
to apartment complexes are you
delivering on time in certain countries
you do need the data but then you need
to check that data with your intuition
and your instincts and you need to teach
that to the all the senior executives
and and junior executives to rule number
eight never be satisfied the great thing
about humans in general is we're always
improving things and so entrepreneurs
and inventors and you know if they
follow their curiosity and they follow
their passions and they figure something
out and then they figure out how to make
it better and they're never satisfied
and and you need to harness that in my
view you need to harness that energy
primarily on your customers instead of
on your competitors and so where I see I
sometimes see companies and even young
small start-up companies entrepreneurs
go awry is they start to pay more
attention to their competition than they
do to their customers and I think that
that I think that in big mature
industries that
can be that might be a winning approach
in some cases kind of close following
let other people be the pioneers and you
know and go down the blind alleys
there's many things that a new inventive
company tries won't work
and so those mistakes and errors and
failures do cost real money and and and
so maybe in a mature industry that where
growth rates are slow and change is very
slow but as you see in the world more
and more there aren't very many mature
industries change is happening
everywhere you know we see it in the
automobile industry with self-driving
cars and but you could go right down the
line of every industry and you would see
it rule number nine make it happen
what was your moment you thought I might
not make it the riskiest moment for
Amazon charlie was at the very very
beginning I needed to raise a million
dollars at a certain point and I ended
up giving away 20% of the company for a
million dollar hell of a deal for
somebody a lot of people did very well
in that deal but they but they also took
a risk so they deserve to do very well
on that deal but I I had to take 60
meetings to raise a million dollars and
I raced it from 22 people at
approximately fifty thousand dollars a
person and it was nip and tuck whether I
was gonna go raise that money so the
whole thing could have ended before he
even started that was 1995
you know and the first question every
investor asked me was what's the
internet and rule number 10 the last one
before very special bonus clip is laughs
I loved high school I had so much fun we
had I lost my library privileges because
I laughed too loudly in the library and
that laughs where did you get that
laughter um you know it is distinctive
I've had that laugh all my life there
was a short not that short there was a
multi-year period where my brother and
sister would not see a movie with me
because they thought it was too
embarrassing
and my but I don't know why I have this
laughs it's just it's just and I laughs
easily and often the people who know me
you know yes my mom or anybody who knows
me well and they'll say if Jeff's
unhappy wait five minutes now I've got a
special bonus gift from Jeff on how to
focus on your core values that I think
is gonna help but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one what's the thing that you need to
just make happen this week number two
what is being a good leader mean to you
and number three what does a day one
culture look like for your business and
if you're gonna take some action after
this video give me a hashtag believe
down in the comments as well we do so
many different things so this is a
question I started get how can you do so
many different things why don't you
stick to the Knitting the kind of
traditional advice would be to stay
focused and keep the business simple and
the way I think about this is we
actually do stick to one thing it's just
not described it's something the
business is so if we do web services
which is you know big Enterprise is
buying compute services from us and we
have our retail business and we have
Amazon Studios which is making original
content and with long ago the things you
listed so but the cultural thread that
runs through all these things is the
same we only have a few principles of
the Amazon kind of core values that we
go back to over and over again and if
you looked at each of the things that we
do you would see those run straight
through everything so the first one and
by far the most important one is
customer obsession and we talk about it
as customer obsession as opposed to
competitor obsession and I have seen
over and over again companies talk about
that their customer focused but really
when I pay close attention to them I
believe they are competitor focused and
that's just a completely different
mentality by the way competitor focus
can work but I don't think it works in
the law
run as well as customer-focused for one
thing once you're the leader if your
whole culture is competitor obsessed
it's kind of hard to stay energized and
motivated if you're out in front where
as customers were always unsatisfied
they're always discontent they always
want more and so no matter how far you
get out there in front of your
competitors you're still behind your
customers so they're always pulling you
along so customer obsession is a deep
principle that underlies everything we
do another one is eagerness to invent so
we love to pioneer and when we have done
by the way whenever we have tried to do
something in a kind of meat to fashion
we have failed at it we need to have
something that is differentiated unique
something that customers are going to
like that we're kind of leading with so
that's another element that works for us
and then another one is long-term
thinking we are willing to to take some
time and be patient with our business
initiatives and that runs through
everything so a lot of our competitors
might have two to three year kind of
timeframes and we might have more of a
five to seven year sort of timeframe and
then the last one operational excellence
so literally you know how do you have
high standards around you know
identifying defects fixing defects at
the root all those kinds of things that
lead to what I think also can be in a
simpler way just stated as
professionalism that you want to do
things right just for the writ sake of
doing the right
if you want jeff bezos his advice on
work-life balance check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I don't even like the
phrase work-life balance I think it's
misleading if you're giving great
customer experience
[Music]